j'ai eu une révélation qui a changé ma vie.
J'étais peintre et décorateur
à Castlemaine, une petite ville au milieu de l'état de Victoria.
J'étais allé voir Pete, qui était connu pour sa maîtrise du travail de l'acier.
Je cherchais une bordure en acier pour mon jardin.
Ce jour-là, avec du recul, ce qui est un cadeau merveilleux,
Pete semblait plus heureux que d'habitude.
Deux semaines plus tard,
je peignais une maison de sa rue
lorsque j'ai appris la tragique nouvelle.
Pete s'était suicidé.
Pete, comme moi, était un ouvrier.
On aime raccourcir les mots dans le jargon australien.
Un ouvrier.
Il y a des attentes dans ce métier.
Vous êtes censé être stoïque.
Vous êtes censé être fort,
robuste, macho.
Vous êtes censé être fort physiquement
et silencieux face à l'adversité.
L'effet de ricochet est fort
lorsque quelqu'un se suicide dans votre communauté.
L'enterrement de Pete était en juillet. C'était l'hiver.
L'ambiance était morne et sombre
dans cette salle remplie de gens.
C'était une communauté en deuil
qui n'avait aucune réponse
au suicide de Pete.
Aucune réponse.
Je me promenais entre les ouvriers et les membres de la communauté,
et j'ai commencé à entendre d'autres choses tragiques.
J'ai entendu des gens parler dans cette salle
des problèmes auxquels d'autres personnes faisaient face.
L'essence de ces conversations pouvait se résumer en quatre mots,
entendus plusieurs fois :
Qui est le prochain ?
Ce fut une révélation.
C'était le moment où je me tenais dans cette salle,
dans un endroit où la communauté de Castlemaine
m'avait apporté tant de soutien depuis 20 ans,
cette communauté qui avait soutenu mon travail,
j'y ai joué au foot, j'y ai fait du théâtre,
j'étais si reconnaissant de ce qu'elle m'avait offert.
Mais je me tenais là,
et je regardais autour de moi aussi,
et je savais qui dans cette salle
avait des problèmes d'alcool, de drogue, d'argent, avec le jeu,
de violence domestique, de harcèlement.
Et pourtant, à cause de ma culture d'ouvrier,
et des œillères qu'on garde dans notre communauté,
je ne me sentais pas du tout sûr de moi.
Je n'avais pas les outils. Je manquais d'expérience.
Je ne savais pas quoi faire, mais je voulais faire quelque chose.
J'ai quitté la veillée.
J'ai embrassé des amis ouvriers et j'ai dit :
« Viens me voir si tu as besoin. »
Mais je ne savais pas quoi leur dire.
Je n'en avais aucune idée.
Deux semaines après, Catherine Pilgrim, ma cofondatrice, m'a appelé.
Elle voulait aider la famille.
Nous avons parlé puis j'ai dit :
« Faisons quelque chose pour la communauté ouvrière.
On aime notre ville, on est reconnaissants,
faisons quelque chose pour elle. »
On a parlé un peu plus.
Que pouvions-nous faire ?
Un événement de sensibilisation. Formidable.
C'est d'ouvriers qu'on parle.
Comment inciter des ouvriers à aller quelque part ?
Peut-on les amener dans un hôpital ? Non.
Dans un centre de santé ? Non.
La culture d'ouvrier est profondément enracinée.
Quel est l'endroit parfait où réunir les ouvriers
où ils se sentent intégrés,
où ils se sentent à l'aise,
où ils peuvent partager, se confier et parler de santé mentale
dans le Bâtiment ?
Où organiser un événement ?
Dans une quincaillerie.
(Rires)
Oui, c'était ma réaction aussi. J'ai trouvé ça très malin.
Plus précisément, l'entrepôt à bois d'une quincaillerie.
Et voilà on y était, on avait le lieu.
De quoi d'autre a-t-on besoin ?
Qu'est-ce que les ouvriers aiment ?
Manger.
Comme tout le monde, mais eux adorent ça.
Nous, les ouvriers,
on adore les sandwichs œuf-bacon.
L'idée, c'était de donner des sandwichs œuf-bacon aux ouvriers
et on avait notre slogan :
« Sauve ta peau. »
C'est un peu ringard mais ça fonctionne.
Et on a aussi trouvé un logo.
[HALT] Espoir et soutien pour les ouvriers.
Gardez à l'esprit, que HALT, notre association, n'avait pas d'argent,
rien, pas un sou.
On a discuté.
C'est un problème communautaire. Il faut commencer par la communauté.
Alors on est allé chez le boucher, chez le boulanger,
on n'avait pas de fabricant de bougies.
On avait une crèmerie et du chocolat,
du café, des fruits,
On faisait du porte à porte :
« On organise un événement de sensibilisation.
Vous voulez nous aider ? On n'a pas beaucoup d'argent. »
Bien sûr, presque chaque personne avec qui on discutait
connaissait quelqu'un d'anxieux, de dépressif, qui pensait au suicide
ou qui s'était suicidé.
On avait cette unité,
cette approche communautaire.
Donc on s'est dit : « Cool, on a à manger. Quoi d'autre ? »
Il faut que les services d'assistance soient là.
Beaucoup d'ouvriers et d'hommes en général
ne savent pas forcément où demander de l'aide.
Moi-même, j'ai été l'un d'eux,
et voilà de quoi je parle aux événements d'HALT :
quand j'ai fondé HALT il y a quatre ans,
je ne savais pas que je pouvais consulter un docteur à propos de ma santé mentale
ou bien me faire soigner.
La santé communautaire m'était inconnue.
Je ne savais bien sûr rien de SOS Suicide,
je les ai appelés trois fois,
et ils m'ont sans doute sauvé la vie.
J'ai dû apprendre tout ça.
Les ouvriers doivent savoir ça.
On a distribué des sacs,
des sacs d'information,
et beaucoup d'ouvriers m'ont dit la première année :
« Waouh, ça fait beaucoup de m**** »
mais je sais que ces ouvriers ont toujours ces sacs dans leur pick-up
ou leur hangar.
Le 10 novembre 2013,
la manifestation a eu lieu
et c'est intéressant, quand je parle d'approche communautaire,
notre premier événement était à Castlemaine chez les frère Tonks
et toute la communauté était là.
Des thérapeutes,
des gens qui ont souffert de problèmes mentaux.
Ce premier événement a donné le ton.
Depuis, on a organisé d'autres événements.
Curieusement, les ouvriers ne sont pas les seuls
à souffrir de problèmes mentaux, à être angoissés, dépressifs ou suicidaires.
On a commencé à travailler avec les centres de formation pour adultes,
dans le domaine agricole,
dans les comités, les universités.
On a organisé des manifestations pour les compagnes des ouvriers,
parce que les ouvriers ne voulaient pas rentrer chez eux
et dire : « On a parlé de santé mentale,
et maintenant, on va faire ça, ça, et ça. »
Donc des rencontres pour les compagnes
qui ont parfois besoin d'aide.
Ces cours pour adultes sont populaires.
Il est crucial d'atteindre ces jeunes gens vulnérables.
On s'est intéressé aux abris,
parce que le taux de suicide est élevé chez les plus vieux.
On a organisé des événements pour les fonctionnaires municipaux.
C'est intéressant,
presque à chaque manifestation -
et on en a organisé, avec très peu de fonds,
150 dans quatre États.
Donc - oh merci.
(Applaudissements)
Et à chaque événement, même dans une quincaillerie,
un ouvrier vient me voir,
au moins un, et il me parle de sa tentative de suicide.
Ils ne sont plus suicidaires, ils ont réglé leurs problèmes,
mais ces hommes n'ont jamais pensé qu'ils pouvaient parler de leur vulnérabilité.
Ils n'ont jamais pensé pouvoir parler de leur tentative de suicide,
mais les événements HALT,
où on n'attend pas d'eux qu'ils parlent,
les mettent assez à l'aise pour qu'ils s'expriment.
Et ils ne font pas que me parler et me raconter leur histoire,
maintenant, ils disent :
« On se sent suffisamment à l'aise pour parler avec d'autres. »
J'en ai vu se lever et dire :
« Je ne l'ai jamais dit, mais j'ai fait une dépression,
et si quelqu'un ici veut venir me parler,
je suis là. »
C'est très valorisant et cathartique.
On a besoin d'une approche communautaire.
On donne les infos des services d'assistance locaux et nationaux
C'est bien de dire à un ouvrier lors de ces manifestations :
« Tu devrais aller là, là et là »
mais une approche communautaire
est nécessaire pour intégrer la prévention du suicide.
On a besoin de ces organismes,
et le suicide ne fait pas de distinctions.
Ça n'arrive pas juste de 9h à 17h.
Il faut organiser des rencontres avant 9h, comme nos petits déj',
et après 17h.
Voilà ce qu'il faut faire. C'est une approche communautaire.
Il faut atteindre les entreprises.
Il faut atteindre les clubs sportifs, les clubs sociaux.
Il faut entrer et éduquer les gens
sur les problèmes de santé mentale.
Voilà quelques statistiques qui donnent à réfléchir.
En 2016,
en Australie, il y a eu 2 866 suicides,
deux fois le nombre d'accidents de la route.
800 000 suicides en un an
dans le monde,
un toutes les 40 secondes.
On a besoin d'une approche communautaire.
On doit se sentir à l'aise pour engager une discussion.
Les hommes que je connais ont du mal à s'ouvrir.
C'est sûr.
Je leur dis : « Si vous allez engager la discussion,
il faut trouver un endroit où on se sent à l'aise pour parler,
que ce soit dans un pub, ou pendant une promenade,
après le foot.
Trouvez cet endroit où vous vous sentez à l'aise pour parler. »
Savoir parler de ces choses,
c'est déjà savoir quoi dire.
On a tous entendu parler du : « Ça va ? »
Et je l'ai vu. Je l'ai dit.
« Ça va ? - Oui. - Ça va ? -Oui.
- Ça va ? - Oui. - Ça va ? - Non. »
Maintenant, je dis quoi ?
Je dis quoi ?
Il faut donner à chacun
la capacité d'oser avoir cette conversation.
On doit être capable d'écouter.
Je ne sais pas qui, ici, sait écouter.
J'essaie d'améliorer ma capacité à écouter,
mais écouter sans jugement est une forme d'art.
Ne pas se moquer. Si quelqu'un vient vous parler de maladie mentale,
d'angoisse, de dépression, de pensées suicidaires,
il faut le respecter.
Ils veulent nous faire confiance, qu'on écoute ce qu'ils ont à dire
et qu'on n'en parle à personne.
Nous devons faire cela.
Et donc il faut parler. Il faut écouter.
Et il faut commencer à diminuer la stigmatisation des problèmes mentaux.
Les entreprises mettent en place un jour de la santé mentale.
Quelle bonne idée !
Pas juste la santé, mais la santé mentale.
Les choses sont en train d'évoluer. On peut y contribuer.
Je suis une bouée de sauvetage.
Je pense que nous pouvons tous l'être.
La douleur des regrets
est bien pire que la douleur d'un dur labeur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)